all right welcome back to CBS this
morning I'm 22 Copa with Gayle King and
Anthony Mason and we begin with this
only on CBS this morning the father of a
Sandy Hook victim is telling us about
his fight against misinformation and
this comes after a major legal ruling
against a man who called the mass
shooting a hoax
a Wisconsin jury ordered James Fetzer
who co-wrote a book called nobody died
at Sandy Hook to pay four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for defaming
Lenny Posner posner six-year-old son
Noah was killed in that 2012 shooting
and Posner has made it his mission to
change tech company policies to protect
victims from online bullying he's made
progress but also enemies and as a
result we agreed not to show what he
looks like for his own protection
how many death threats have you received
oh there have been dozens and and there
are threats that are just posted that I
may have not even seen many Posner says
he's been forced to move at least a half
dozen times since the death of his son
Noah one of twenty children and six
adults killed in the 2012 shooting at
Connecticut's Sandy Hook elementary
school while still grieving
Posner faced a new shock as strangers
claimed that the shooting had never
really happened what did you find online
in the talk of conspiracy theories the
talk of crisis actors the talk of a
staged event to take away people's gun
rights most people probably would have
just walked away and you didn't I never
thought I had the option to walk away
because because that was my life now the
father of a murdered child
the name associated to an online
conspiracy theory' Posner funneled his
anger into action asking social media
platforms to take down the posts at
first with little luck most of the time
there was an automatic robotic response
you're not even dealing with a person it
never even got to a person but in the
Year sense this unlikely activist has
not only succeeded for himself he's
helping others through his organization
honor network whose volunteers keep an
eye on the Internet protecting victims
of tragedy cyber stalking and harassment
people like Andy Parker I felt sick
after his daughter Allison was shot to
death on live TV in 2015
conspiracy theorist reposted the video
again claiming it was a fake
Parker contacted YouTube to get the
videos taken down I thought I could do
it just you know one time and be done
with it and they said no you have to do
it for each video
yeah it's tantamount to saying watch
your daughter's murder and then tell us
why over and over again over and over
again
and then tell a robot why this needs to
come down
that's essentially what they told me to
do but Posner had a better idea
he held parker get the rights to the
video allowing him to force their
removal in bulk on copyright grounds and
it worked it was just a matter of who
can help me with this and i knew i was
learning more recently many large tech
companies have updated their policies on
harassment so what role do you think
you've personally played in getting
Facebook and Google and YouTube and
WordPress to change their policies I
think that had I not shamed them
publicly using the press that none of
that would have happened in the way that
it has happened in confronting
misinformation Posner has also changed
Minds
I think it could be summed up with the
term sandy hoax Dave Canaries company
published James Fetzer's book nobody
died at Sandy Hook which prompted Posner
to sue in the first place but as Posner
spoke at a deposition get Harry had a
revelation I'm listening to him and I I
decided
I determined that what he was saying was
authentic and I wanted to do what I
could do to not contribute to the
negative things that he's experiencing
Gary settled the case and now Fetzer is
on the hook for a four hundred and fifty
thousand dollar verdict in Wisconsin and
Posner says his work is just getting
started
so is this fight crusade mission near on
does it take up your life I mean this is
what you do this has become my life's
work yeah this is your life's work you
know that's what it's turned into does
it still feel good when you get
something taken down it feels right
Lenny Posner is also suing internet
personality outlets Jones for defamation
for spreading false information about
the Sandy Hook shootings Jones's
attorneys are using free speech
arguments to try to get the case
dismissed because it that Posner says
this is not about other people's free
speech it's about people like him and
other victims their freedom from
harassment yes absolutely yes and
considering what he's gone through it's
it's very sad that this has to be his
life's work yes that he would now be
subjected to that tell you what he is
making progress it's fascinating that it
took a copyright situation to pull a
video down when something that was was
toxic and hateful was allowed to stay
the tech companies don't know how to
deal with grieving parents but they do
know how to deal with lawyers and the
fear of lawsuits and say it worked it
worked
she doesn't have to head to that all
right